hello how you doing welcome to
PlayStation grenade usually at the end
of the season I go through all the map
changes from the last ten weeks by then
though it's too late to talk about the
evolving storyline so I'm going to try
out a weekly map evolution and storyline
update series let me know if you'd like
it to stay and more importantly please
share your opinions on future events
battle royale Island has seen five major
updates this week so let's break them
down the der burger and pizza pit
companies have been each other's throats
for seasons and since the original pizza
pit was ripped through time replaced
with a temple and the og der burger went
out of business the two companies have
set up shop in retail row it became a
tit-for-tat battle
first the der burger added seating for
their customers before the pizza pit
crew outright built a new storefront
this week the der burger has hit back
once again and erected their own
permanent building complete with iconic
sign but wait a minute it's incomplete
we could see a new mascot placed upon
the sign or most likely will see the
original der burger brought back from
the top of the hill next to pleasant
park and slowly over the next few weeks
return to its new home in retail row
inside they've got during's they've got
extra-greasy deep fried in lard fries
they've even got their own Krabby
Patties spongebob will be happy and I
was gonna do a joke about this
restaurant giving you crabs yeah let's
not do about at this point it's a once
again be Pizza pits turn to escalate
this drama and keep in mind there are
other food emporium here and they could
join the food fight the bacon Hut in
happy Hamlet the noodle shop in lucky
landing the taco stand still lay dormant
and I still hold a faint hope for the
tender defender to follow his dreams and
make a legit KFC in fortnight before we
move on a quick thank you to those
people who've used my code a tomorrow in
the fort night shop you make this video
possible you have my utmost respect
thank you so much so I was on my way to
see if the der burger was being moved
and stopped off at leaky Lake to look
around the Stonehenge left behind by
Kevin the cube last season is seriously
degrading the
locks are crumbling disintegrating this
location will change and soon
but how please let me know your thoughts
in the comments what will happen to
leaky Lake over in pleasant Park
something is being set up on the
football field it looks like a stage
which should perfectly coincide with the
Superbowl finale on Sunday as the Los
Angeles Rams take on the New England
Patriots personally I don't have a team
so I'm from Old England so I'll cheer on
New England especially down into tilted
towers the building under construction
is finally finished at last let's
reminisce for a second first the office
building was destroyed by the meteor
then the Sport Shop was destroyed by
Kevin the cube and now we may have a
building which sticks around for more
than a few weeks because we finally have
a TV station in fortnight Battle Royale
this will link into all those magical TV
sets around the world which suddenly
spring into life every so often and look
on top of the building
the satellite dish is up and running as
a note we may need to keep an eye on
where it's pointing to this could be
important in the future inside the TV
studio is a great kitchen set and a few
green screen areas this one is my
favorite it even has a view through to
the director of course not everything is
going to plan though the shoddy
workmanship has already led to a few
problems with the flaws so watch your
step on the outside the flatbed truck
still remains here so maybe there's
something yet to be added possibly a
sign for the studio if it is a studio
name try and guess it below if you get
it right I'll send you some ebooks also
note that the old junk from the previous
store owner is on its way to junk the
junction I'll keep an eye on it and let
you know of its demise
so now the big one over to Pola peek
if you've been paying attention you'll
know the ice has been melting in the
dungeon of the castle we've seen torture
racks we've seen unsavory tools of
torment heck we've even seen dragon eggs
as the ice melted away we saw a
character in shackles slowly Thorin out
last week his arm became visible take
note of his skin is similar to igneous
rock like those found from meteors that
have cooled on earth or on the other
hand natural igneous rock here on earth
comes from volcanic heat signifying this
chap stuck here is indeed the opposite
of the Ice King expect flames to fly
true to form those hackers have already
uncovered the hidden skin which comes
out next week so if you don't want
spoilers please turn off now I wouldn't
want to ruin anything for you okay and
thank God good so here's the character
we will unlock his skin is indeed heat
modified as his skin evolves it shows
flames upon his head his shoulders his
chest fire Thanos has officially arrived
this leads to so much more conjecture
and so many questions
will we see fire versus ice will we see
a volcano finally rise from the icy
landscape will this snow fall character
be the catalyst to the Cataclysm
promised in season 3 is this going to be
Ragnarok so many options so many
possible outcomes so please start the
dialogue below by the way I don't get
through all the comments so if you want
to talk to me directly come find me on
Twitter to be honest I'd be thankful for
people to talk to over there anyway once
again thanks to those people who use add
tomorrow in the shop remember to send me
a pic if you use my code and I'll give
you a shout out next time I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]